[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 27th of
may
i'm fraser nelson your host for today's
show
now we've got several things lined up
tonight the first
is joe biden's investigation into the
origins of the covet leak might it have
come from a wuhan lab
after all we talked to matt ridley who's
written the cover story on this
for us then dominic cummings what's the
damage report from his explosive
revelations in westminster this week
we speak to james forsyth katie balls
and craig oliver
cameron's former spin doctor then we
talked to professor snitra gupta
dominic cummings said in testimony that
she'd advocated a herd immunity strategy
does she agree
with his assessment then over to belarus
where we're going to be asking owen
matthews what to make
of the extraordinary decision to
forcibly land
a ryanair jet and march off it a
belarusian
dissident and then finally is sweden
ready for a work
monarchy lisa burewald looks at
developments over there and asks if
prince harry
is more of a pioneer than a pariah no
first before we do this we'd like to
make what is a if you ask me
a financially unsensible special offer
we're going to be offering a 20 pound
amazon voucher to anybody
who takes over a 12 pound subscription
to the spectator a trial subscription
for three months three months of the
magazine three months online
offered 12 pounds and you get 20 quid
from amazon
and that's on spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer and now on to our
first item
when matt ridley first heard the theory
that kovid was actually cooked up in a
chinese laboratory
he dismissed it as being a conspiracy
theory on the lines of ufo landings and
elvis still being alive but after a year
looking into it he thinks there's a lot
more to this theory perhaps
why joe biden has now instructed the
american intelligence services
to reopen their investigation into what
previously had seemed to be a donald
trump conspiracy
madness he joins me now matt thanks very
much for your cover piece
why did you start looking into this
because for a long time
nobody sensible thought this made sense
yeah it's a it's it's it's a really
interesting point i mean i started out
from the assumption that
mother nature is a better genetic
engineer than we are and so it would be
hard we'd be hard put in a lab to to
come up with something this
this infectious this efficient this
lethal
um and then as i began to look into it i
started interviewing scientists for
an article in the wall street journal
about the origin of the virus and
the bats and the pangolins and all that
kind of stuff is that it was emerging in
the spring of 2020
and i i could you know it was clear that
it didn't quite add up and some of them
were uh
was saying well don't worry it will add
up but it it
you know the the market theory began to
collapse
and then in may 2020 two things happened
one a paper came out from a scientist
named alina chan and her colleagues
in boston
saying this virus was very well adapted
to human cells from the very beginning
that's unlike sars which took months to
evolve
rapidly to become a uh
good at infecting people and the other
thing that happened that same week
was the head of the chinese cdc said
we've tested all the animals in the
market and they're all negative
now that was very quietly announced they
didn't want that news to be
a big splash but you put those two
together and you say well hang on
if it didn't come out the market and it
was well adapted to human beings from
the start
maybe it's been playing around in human
cells in the lab
and then one started looking into the uh
the labs
in wuhan and what they were doing and
finding that actually of all the cities
in the world
this is the one that has been studying
bat coronaviruses more than any other
laboratory on the entire planet
and it has been collecting thousands of
samples
and the nearest relative which was
collected by the scientists from this
lab was collected from
more than 1200 miles away by road during
one of seven collecting trips
to one particular mine shaft and that in
the months afterwards
more and more attempts were made to find
closely related viruses and none have
been as close as that one collected by
the scientists and brought to the
laboratory
so for me it was very much a journey of
discovery right but surely
if you're doing research into that you
take all sorts of precautions if the
american government itself
is sending millions of american taxpayer
dollars onto this
they will be pretty sure but these will
be done in a controlled way i mean
nuclear energy is very dangerous but all
precautions are made to make sure it
doesn't seep out
surely the chinese would have that
covered the idea that you
might just wander home with a new
pathogen capable of killing millions i
mean
surely precautions would have been taken
and the american authorities would have
to be confident
that those precautions were being taken
otherwise they wouldn't fund the program
in the first place
well very interestingly in 2018 uh the
american embassy in beijing sent a
delegation to wuhan to look at the wuhan
institute of virology
specifically to look at its biosecurity
level 4 lab which is the highest
biosecurity level
that's the one which you do ebola
research in
funnily enough sars does not require bsl
4 it requires bsl3 and they
made several suggestions about how this
wasn't being
uh the safety and security procedures
were not good enough
and ought to be improved this was uh
china's only
and first biosecurity level four lab was
in wuhan at this institute
now as i say they were doing experiments
in bsl3 on
sars itself but the bat
viruses the ones they were collecting in
the wild from bats which were
not very good infecting people most of
them
uh uh they were doing that at
biosecurity level
two and that was what the international
rules said by the way
now in bsl4 you're in a
spacesuit you're breathing through an
air tube
you know there's negative positive
pressure in your
suit so that you can't you know if you
puncture it nothing comes in
um bsl 3 it's not quite like that you
are
at least breathing the air but uh you
are
totally enclosed in a suit and you're
working within a sealed cabinet which is
negative pressure
bsl two you're just wearing goggles a
mask and a lab coat
that's it nothing else right so this
sounds like a
you paint a picture i guess a plausible
picture
of a sort of chernobyl style disaster
and you know the history of
everything from the titanic sinking
onwards you know you the best laid
security plans of mice men and nuclear
scientists go aft
aglay but surely what you're missing
right now it still is just that it's a
theory you're
all you're saying effectively is it
could have come from the lab sure
nobody denies that but whether it did
come from a lab
the best evidence you've got is that we
do have not yet
identified the missing link that we
found with sars
one in other words they managed to get
to the original batcave they managed to
to connect the dots between animals and
human the first time around
nobody's managed to connect with dots
between animals and humans
this time around and that you're saying
well what about a lab leak
sure it's plausible but it's not
conclusive the chinese government still
described this as a absolutely crazy to
fan up racial discrimination
and xenophobia the when this was
mentioned then
back in april the washington post
described it as a conspiracy theory
the new york times that it was a fringe
theory the landsat has already published
a statement by
several scientists and condemning
conspiracy theories suggesting covert 19
does not
have a natural origin so surely a great
many people
including very esteemed scientists have
dismissed
this theory as bunken well that is
changing
a year ago a great many scientists as
you say
signed up to this view that it was a
conspiracy theory and
a fringe idea and the problem was donald
trump was in favor of this idea and that
made it automatically
anathema to a lot of people but they
confused two things
one was the deliberate bioweapon
synthetic virus idea and the other was
handling viruses in the laboratory in an
accident
and frankly the latter has always been
much more plausible
you're seeing a lot of scientists now
climbing back off
over the fence to say actually we
realize that this is possible
um one of the signatories of that letter
in the lancet that you mentioned
has said uh actually i think it it it
needs to be investigated
one of the authors of a key paper called
the proximal origins of
sarsko v2 which was a very influential
paper in march last year
has now said he thinks it deserves to be
investigated so more and more scientists
have now changed their view and said yes
it does need to be investigated
but you are right that we have no direct
proof of a lab leak there's no record of
an incident and more importantly
there's no record of this particular
virus being experimented on
now you might the the wuhan institute of
virology
says look if we'd had this virus in the
lab we'd have published it
well would you in in in february last
year they published
the virus the genome of the virus that
was
closest related to this and they'd had
that since 2013.
so they don't publish things immediately
they had a database with
22 000 entries in it 15 000 of which
were about bat viruses
they were both data on where it was
collected but also genome sequences and
partial genome sequences
now that database 22 000 items went
offline on the 12th of september
2019 before the pandemic began
and they've come up with all sorts of
excuses why they won't share now
what was in it they say well there are
hacking attempts to it
well all the more reason to to show
legitimate
inquiries what's in that that database
um
also when they publish that related
virus
that's the closest relative of sarsko v2
um in february last year they disguised
its origin
changed its name did not mention the
fact that three people had died
in the mine shaft where it was collected
and didn't say that they'd found eight
other similar viruses at the same time
now that is not the behavior of
a group that thinks it's innocent now it
says it's innocent and you know the
chinese government says it couldn't have
come out of
the lab but in that case be transparent
open your books show us what you've got
and we will no doubt be utterly
convinced
well that question of innocence and i
guess the question of who done it
is the cover of this week's spectator
matt ridley's article
is there a matthew thanks very much for
joining us on spectator
tv now we're going to the other big
story of this week dominic cummings
explosive revelations
in westminster where he had plenty to
say about the prime minister and how a
delaying lockdown he says led to
thousands of deaths
i'm joined by katie balls james forsyth
and by
craig oliver who was david cameron's
spokesman in number 10
for a while thank you all for joining me
craig let's start with you you were
dominick cummings adversary for a while
in the brexit campaign what do you think
he's up to and how do you
gauge his sort of behavior at the moment
i think it's very complicated and i
think that is the biggest theme
of this dominic cummings is a genius in
terms of campaigning he's very very good
at making things very binary black or
white
hero villain up or down and i think you
sort of saw yesterday the tragedy of
somebody
who has portrayed the world in that way
and often seen the world in that way
dealing with the fact that actually in
reality it's quite complicated it's
messy it's difficult there are flawed
human beings there's imperfect
information
and then as a result of that chaos
ensues and i think that there was a real
tension between him wanting to have a
kind of perfect dynamic
and the reality of a complicated and
difficult situation and
he just seemed not to be able to just
see that james what do you think the
dam what do you think with the most
damaging revelations that we heard in
this sort of
six seven hour evidence session from
dominic cummings well i mean the most
the most damaging one is the idea that
tens of thousands of people have died
who needn't have died because of
mistakes that the government has made i
mean
specifically delaying lockdown that's
the big that is
the arch mistake to his mind it is the
delay in locking down in both
march and and in the autumn that are
responsible for that right
and and do you think take matt hancock
he was the number one target
what is katie do you think matt
hancock's
future is now is he now a dead man
walking in a strange way
actually having a series of damaging
allegations and dominant comings claim
that you should have been sacked by now
for 15 to 20 reasons could be helpful to
matt hancock
uh in the sense that there has been talk
for some times that uh
downing street would like to move matt
hancock even maybe even matt hancock
would like to leave the health brief
um but i think were uh boris wants to
move now
on that it could look as though he was
listening to what dominic cummings was
saying
that dominic cummings had a point and
number 10 don't want to say dominic
cummings has a point about anything
because then they have might have a
point about the prime minister so
perhaps now it's actually harder to move
about hancock
right now one of the most interesting
clips was when dominic cummings
said that he had personally lost faith
in boris johnson and as a result
created a mechanism to get around it
here's what he had to say
by the 31st of october our relations
were essentially already finished the
fact that his girlfriend
also wanted rid of me was you know
relevant but not
the heart of the heart of the problem
the problem was uh
fundamentally i regarded him as unfit
for the job and i was trying to create a
structure around him
to try and stop what i thought were
extremely bad decisions and push other
things through against his wishes
and he had the view that he was prime
minister and i should just be doing as
he wanted me to and that's obviously not
sustainable for very long
so craig what did you think about that
it stretches the powers of an advisor
somewhat doesn't it
i think it does and i think that this is
another problem for dominic cummings
that he perhaps hadn't
spotted he has a bit of a credibility
problem here
he was briefing very very hard that he
was effectively the most powerful person
in the country
he made very clear that he was only
taking the job on the understanding that
he had complete control
and the ability to do that he said that
on the record he was very very clear
about that
and i think coming up afterwards as well
and saying oh look i've only just
realized that boris johnson
isn't the master of detail and sometimes
changes his mind on things well
come on we've known this guy for a long
time we all knew who he was we know how
he was when he was mayor of london we
know how he was when he was working for
the spectator and the telegraph
and whatever and people know this
information so for dominic coming to
come out and say
only under this pressure did i realize
who i was actually working with
it just really stretches credibility a
bit much i think right
and and james what how powerful was
dominic cummings it wasn't quite
clear he was saying he was an advisor to
the prime minister that was it
he basically says he lost the argument
about lockdown several times so it
didn't sound
from all apologies he was making
yesterday as if he was that powerful so
was he exaggerating
and how powerless he was or when he was
in office
were people exaggerating how powerful he
was
so dominant cummings made this uh point
and he said you know my
his ability to to affect change in
downing street was limited he pointed
out how
he had wanted to kind of reorganize uh
where everyone sat and
then he said that he hadn't been able to
achieve that but at another point in his
testimony he talked about
bringing in simon case to be the cabinet
secretary now simon cases
is very young and him getting the job
was you know that was a sign or
i i think of of a change to the kind of
the classic
civil service uh processes i i think
that dominant cummings was a very
powerful figure in downing street
but he was not the prime minister and i
think ultimately
in some ways that was where some of the
tension in yesterday's testimonies
came from which is you know the dominant
cummings could get his way on
on on anything where boris johnson did
not
actively disagree with him and but and
there were undoubtedly some decisions on
when and where to when to lock down
where
boris johnson actively disagreed with
him and
and that was why he wasn't getting his
way but i mean i think his i think his
rit
ran up to the point where it conflicted
with that of boris johnson who was after
all the prime minister and katie
is there now a dominant coming-sized
hall in number 10. if you look at how he
described
his rule yesterday he was putting
together meetings he drawing a plan
b on the blackboard convening people it
seems that he was
you know certainly by his own emissions
and pretty powerful
so what's happened now in number 10 is
there somebody else coordinating it or
is there just to drift
i think there was a revealing moment in
dominic cummings testimony when he
talked about how he thought about
leaving his job a few times and at one
point has said to the prime minister
well look you're more scared of me than
the chaos you get without me and he
alleges that boris johnson replied
saying well
chaos isn't so bad when you have a
chaotic situation everyone looks to me
i think that's interesting if you uh
think about recent events in number 10
some of which involved briefing against
dominic cummings when they've been at
rise and
lots of people saying who is in charge
other than boris johnson
and i don't there's a specific aid now
he was seen as the most senior yes
you've got dan rosenfield
who is technically the chief of staff
but i don't think there is that
heavyweight figure in the way that
dominic cummings was but also perhaps
that is what boris johnson wants
now craig dominic cummings says he now
thinks the prime minister is not fit for
office is reasonable to assume
that he's going to be making more
interventions perhaps aimed
at removing that prime minister from
officer certainly destabilizing him
within it
do you think he'll be successful in that
campaign because after all
he campaigned against you during the
referendum and he got the better review
might he get the better of boris johnson
now no he certainly did and it was it
was highly effective and
it worked very well um i'm sort of
reminded of that sort of line in king
lear where
there's a where he's raging in the storm
and he's saying i shall do such things i
know not what
we sort of heard this raging quite a lot
there's been a number of occasions where
dominic cummings has said that he's
going to reveal
a whole load of stuff there was a whole
little briefing to the sunday papers
about what we were going to discover and
that kind of thing
and ultimately i think it's going to
it's falling short the reality is it was
incredibly
fascinating to watch yesterday but in
reality what it delivered was a lot of
color and not really much that was
substantially new
we knew that there was a scandal about
what happened in care homes in this
country
we knew that there was a huge row about
whether or not there should be a second
lockdown
and i think most people know and feel
that yes we did lock down too late
but just going back to the point that
katie was making this is a government if
we're honest
that is riding high despite everything
else it is doing incredibly well in the
polls
it did very well in the last election
and it did that without dominic coming
so
that's an interesting factor to take on
board as well right but james what we
didn't know was we didn't know that the
health secretary was so mistrusted by
the cabinet secretary
the cabinet secretary was saying matt
hancock is a congenital liar
i can't trust him we didn't know that
boris johnson
told dominic cummings that um that matt
hancock is the sort of person you keep
in his job now
so you can fire him later now surely
these revelations do move the dial in
westminster
yeah i i think i think as katie has said
on coffee house one of the things that
dominant coming
testimony will do is stir up
tensions and trouble within the cabinet
and
and and within downing street because
you are revealing
an awful lot about what people said
behind closed doors about their
colleagues and the like
and so i mean that will undoubtedly be
true i think one of the the challenges
for
for for dominant comings is that in his
evidence yesterday he was trying to make
two separate cases that slightly cut
against each other
one is that the whole system failed and
the other is that the prime minister and
the health secretary aren't up to a job
i mean the problem with that is if you
basically emphasize all the deficiencies
in the system people think oh well it
wouldn't have made that much difference
who the prime minister and the health
secretary were if that was
the problem and if you tell people the
problem is that the prime minister and
the house actually
aren't up to the job they do people
think well well maybe if a system had
been led better it would have worked i
think
i think craig talked about how the the
clarity that dominic cummings brings to
campaigns
i think one of the problems for his
argument yesterday was
but it wasn't a simple either it's the
system's fault
or it's the prime minister's fault he
was arguing was a mix of a two
and that's a more difficult uh and
nuanced case to make
and and craig oliver would you go back
into number 10 now is there anything
that could persuade you because it
sounds like
boris johnson needs help i i don't think
he'd have
me i think he needs somebody who was
much more in line
with his with his current thinking and i
think actually you know what at the
bottom
end of all of this i think that probably
in number 10 they're not comfortable
they haven't enjoyed what's gone on in
the last
day or so but actually in reality i
think they've seen that
dominic cummings has shot his bolt and
actually
the world didn't end the sky did not
fall in what will be much more
interesting is as we get out of lockdown
and end up in a situation where we
realize
you know there are huge nhs waiting
lists public service is under pressure
does that really have an impact on the
government and then this kind of stuff
starts getting real traction at those
moments
at the moment vaccination programs going
brilliantly we seem to be doing a lot
better than other countries
it's not gaining traction it might do in
a few months
time but at the moment i think they'll
be fairly confident that they've seen
off dominic coming for the time being
well plenty challenges ahead thank you
craig and also as
it says in king lear the plague of our
times is when mad men
lead the blind katie and james thanks
very much for
that and now we'd like to move on
something else dominic cummings said
yesterday
he should have resigned in september he
said after his advice to have a
circuit-breaking lockdown
was rejected he said the prime minister
had started to listen
to experts other than those in the sage
committee
here's what he had to say then on the
sunday evening
there was a meeting with a combination
of sage scientists
and some external people
by this point unfortunately the prime
minister was listening to various people
who were saying things like
there's already heard immunity in the
population there won't be any second
wave etc etc
so we had this meeting in the cabinet
room sunday evening
patrick and chris gave their view um
john sorry um a guy called
hennigan and a woman from
oxford called professor gupta i think it
was
gave the kind of don't lock down
view john edmonds
said he was on stage uh
surely we're going to learn the lessons
of march um here's what the date is
going to be
you are not going to the only logic of
not doing it
not doing a lot down there will be that
you're not going to do it at all
there's no way you're going to make that
decision um
you know just do it now otherwise it's
all going to be worse
prime minister said i'm not persuaded of
that i'm delighted to have one of those
experts joining us
now sinitra gupta is professor of
theoretical epidemiology at the
university
of oxford thanks very much for joining
us on spectator
tv so what did you make of dominick
coming's account
of what you and other outsiders said to
the prime minister when you were called
in
last september i mean first of all in
general i would say it is unfortunate
that the level of discourse
surrounding all of this has settled into
a kind of personal harangue and around
and
accusations fingers of blame being
pointed here and there
what i'd always hoped we would achieve
is a measured debate with different
sides being presented
now instead what's happened and what
we've had to endure and which has
it caused enormous damage to science is
this kind of partisan debate with people
blaming each other
constantly and we've had to suffer a
misrepresentation
of our ideas so for example when
uh dominic cummings said that we
or i had said that we had hit the herd
immunity threshold
this could not be further from the truth
uh all along
my position and it remains so is
that we cannot reliably calculate
a herd immunity threshold for
sales kv2 and also that this threshold
fluctuates
due to seasonality but putting those two
ideas together you can explain what has
happened
in this country and many other countries
including india
as a kind of interaction between the
level of immunity that's acquired
already in the population and where the
herd immunity
threshold is at depending on the season
right but we never said that we were at
heard
immunity um okay so that's one point
yeah and i think actually we've got um
the
written evidence which you gave to that
and
and in that written evidence you say
quite clearly that it's not say
the funny thing about covert is that you
can't tell when you return
immunity um but what was the overall car
i
mean
right now at that meeting it was rare
that people like you
and carl hennigan it was dominantly
coming as correct to say that you were
saying in effect
don't lock down now oh yes i think i
think that would be
a correct representation but that don't
lock down
now uh was not in response not because
we had already reached
herd immunity and therefore didn't need
to worry about a resurgence
don't lock down now was all about
whether lockdown is the appropriate
response and whether more lives
would not have been saved by employing a
complete or
a different strategy um which focused
on where protection was focused on those
rights
but of course your proposal the great
barrington declaration effectively said
that the restrictions should be centered
or protection as you put it should be
centered
on people who are older and vulnerable
and not in the younger so you were
surely
advocating exactly the same thing let
younger people let the key workers if
you want go into society
basically let them get infected and this
was
i put to you a herd immunity strategy
and calling it
any other name is surely semantic and
deception no no
i think that um first of all i don't
think we should even use the term herd
immunity strategy
because herd immunity is not a strategy
it's um
uh if you like it's part of our tool kit
in trying to
live with infectious diseases so we
should be thinking create you know
about how we can develop herd immunity
without paying that
price and of course vaccination is one
of the routes that we can do that
although whether covid vaccines will
allow us to reach our immunities another
question matter completely what we were
advocating
was in fact to shield the essential
workers who were at risk
of dying from kovid those who had
comorbidities so
um what instead we did we
what we did was we locked up the
university students
so i think it was there were strategies
that we could have put in place
which would have protected those who
were actually at risk of death
while allowing those who weren't at
significant risk of death
to conduct their lives normally and be
protected
from other forms of death and um you
know
deficits to their welfare and which at
the same time would
lead as it has actually done to the
growth
of herd immunity in the population this
is for some reason people are in denial
of the fact that actually at the moment
one of the reasons we are enjoying
the situation we currently have is
because there has been
a substantial buildup of herd immunity
in the population
but you still find yourself in a
minority voice among scientists don't
you i mean
we heard from neil ferguson um imperial
college
um only earlier today where he basically
was saying that the decision to delay
lockdown by a week
cost 20 000 lives now that's just not
him saying it from the top of his head
several people very um well-regarded
experts as imperial produced a piece of
work last december
making that exact calculation that
knowing what we know now from lockdown
delaying it by even a week
as the prime minister did in march when
he wasn't listening to dominic cummings
led to a death toll 20 000 higher than
it would otherwise have been that's a
scientific paper surely
um i don't to believe in those results i
think that
you can make a mathematical model in
which you embed a certain assumption
and then from that assumption you get a
certain result
and i don't think that that was
a correct result furthermore um what
we suggested i think would have saved
more lives
so that's it's not as if we suggested
that you should do nothing
if you did nothing that would there
would be a
possibly a tangible difference between
going into lockdown
at least lockdown perhaps saves certain
lives
um but what we suggested was
going into a situation where we
protected those who might die
and allowed those who wouldn't die to
continue with their lives and to prevent
the uh collateral damage that lockdown
um inevitably incur but your theory is
based on several assumptions now
we've um i put to you that everybody got
things wrong but you included i mean the
when quite often during the summer it
was it was said that you had for example
said that herd immunity was achieved
last march
and also i think you said in an
interview that the fatality ratio
would be closer to one in ten thousand
than one
in a thousand those things weren't true
were there
um first of all in terms of with regard
to herd immunity
i don't think as i said before and i
keep saying
i don't think we know what level of herd
immunity was
achieved in may i can easily write down
a mathematical model
in which a high degree of herd immunity
or a large number of people were already
protected from
infection in may of course the herd
immunity threshold itself dropped
because of the summer
and so i would posit that in it was
immunity in the population that kept
surges from occurring through the summer
now my
colleagues would disagree with me and
say no it was a social distancing that
kept
um numbers down but why would it come
back in the autumn
i don't understand i've heard immunity
kept it down in the summer then why
would we see the second wave and
arguably the third wave when the kent
variant came along
um first of all i did say in several
interviews that we would expect a winter
surge
the typical pattern of these respiratory
infections
is that the herd immunity threshold
itself
changes with time so in the summer you
have a low threshold of herd immunity
so even if 25 of the population
happen to be immune that is sufficient
to prevent
the increase in infections as
the temperature drops and other
conditions change
that immunity threshold starts to creep
up
and that's why you inevitably will get
a winter surge an autumn surge and
possibly a spring surge
these are all things that i said in
various interviews
not surprisingly people who choose to
discredit me
pick out one or two quotations
out of context which implied that i
thought the epidemic
was over the pandemic was over now all i
can say to you is if i thought the
pandemic was over
would i have spent the next six months
trying to come up
with a strategy um to handle a
resurgence
of this pandemic um what about the
fatality rates i mean
what's your estimate of that now okay
the fatality rate yes
so that was definitely careless of me to
say
that one in a thousand or ten thousand
is what the average
infection fatality rate is the truth is
that a mean
infection fatality rate is not a very
sensible number
to think about because it's a global
figure isn't there in a national figure
i mean there is some stage where
on a global basis it can be different to
what it is in a country where the
virus is trying to be controlled it you
know
in a country where the age distribution
is different where the comorbidity
distribution is different
you will get a much much lower average
infection fatality rate but it because
infection fatality rate
is not a fundamental property of a
country
it's or the virus itself it's an uh it's
a property that relates to
the host age and condition
i think what i was overzealously trying
to draw
attention to was the fact that most of
us have a very very low
likelihood of dying from infection
unless we are old frail or have certain
comorbidities but certainly um i i
absolutely should not
have um put that number out there right
over as a mean
ifr that was not that's not correct but
overall listening to the seven hours of
dominic cummings
evidence seeing a world's worth of
experiments and lockdowns and also we've
got places like america where
texas took a very different um response
than california
and they had sort of comparable levels
of covet
what do we think the the jury obviously
is out in lockdowns
but um seeing what we see now do you do
you think that dominic cummings
is quite clear in saying that the delay
acting hard and lacking early
cost tens of thousands of lives are you
saying that you are pretty sure that he
is still
incorrect in that view i think first
i think he is incorrect but what's
really important here is that we don't
nobody should be saying anything with
certainty and the beauty of our focus
protection
uh plan is that it is robust to all
these uncertainties
regarding these uncertainties academics
should be having um resp you know
respectful
and um discussions debates
which has not been permitted really in
this whole um
saga but you know really what should be
happening is neil ferguson and i
should be having a publicized debate
uh where we present our assumptions talk
about our solutions
and you know come up maybe we won't
agree
we will respectfully agree to disagree
at the end of it
what we've been trying to do is come up
with a plan that is robust
to these uncertainties and that is
focus protection is such a plan and the
beauty
of it now is that the vaccines allow us
to deliver focused protection without
getting into further debates about
how do we actually implement it how do
we actually
um ask people to self-isolate over a
period of time when
the risk is high how do we separate
people in multi-generational households
all important problems to which i
think there were answers but now we have
a vaccine
which makes it really easy to deliver
focus protection
um so i think this whole
business of being certain and
particularly among
you know people who aren't experts in
the field to
have this certainty and exhibit this
rage
based on a certainty um it mystifies me
i would not have thought
this was how a civilized society
operates
well you certainly have been a victim of
this rage professor gupta and i wonder
at times
what on earth inspired you to go against
the consensus in the way that you did
in an atmosphere where dissenting voices
are um are hounded out and indeed there
was a campaign to discredit you pretty
much run by
a tory mp neil o'brien who is um who was
after you did you not at times think
why did i bother or shouldn't i have
taken the more comfortable life i
imagine
things have been um pretty tough at
times for you
over the summer i wouldn't be surprised
if it doesn't mean some campaign to get
you to resign from university or
something like that
well yes of course it's been very tough
i mean
but but the truth is that i do feel i
have a responsibility
as a scientist and a citizen as a global
citizen
and i do feel very um strongly that was
where i started and that's where i
remain
that uh the collateral damage from
lockdowns
is going to be is profound and in its
final
tally um we will be realizing that this
is just not an appropriate
tool that we have harmed young people
children and and um those
on low incomes and particularly people
in developing countries
to an extent that makes this
lockdown is just not an appropriate tool
and that's why we try to come up with
other tools
that might be appropriate and i still
believe
that focus protection uh is one of those
and now that we have a vaccine
it's possible to deliver that focused
protection
and i think that's what we should get on
with rather than
trying to blame people and um
professor gupta thanks very much indeed
well the cummings show distracted
attention
from a rather important conflagration in
the continent
orion air flights left greece on the way
to vilnius
but ended up making a detour via belarus
where it was landed after fighter jets
sent by the belarusian government
who marched off a dissident who was
thereby arrested
so what can we do about this rather
extraordinary new practice
of what ryanair called a new form of
piracy
plucking dissonance from the sky owen
matthews in this week's magazine
asks how you can solve a problem like
vladimir putin who is
with his ally alexander lukashenko
acting in ways which do challenge the
western norms owen thanks for
joining us so what can we do if anything
about
the newly resurgent and assertive putin
well um we should actually um draw a
distinction is that actually with
this this particular outrage um unlike
all the other outrages unlike the
shooting down malaysian airliner unlike
the poisoning the skripals unlike the
election hacking this one was actually
not putin it was the
shankar and interestingly putin's media
have actually that
doesn't mean any clear condemnation from
the kremlin but putin's
media have actually been quite critical
of lukashenko for his irresponsibility
so i mean that said
your question stands what can we do
whether it's the hijacking of
ryanair flight or whether it's murderers
at loose with
chemical weapons in salisbury and the so
far the best
thing we've come up with or the west has
come up with is sanctions
um and frankly i think it's pretty clear
that
those have failed to dissuade him
because they've been rounds of sanctions
multiple rounds since 2012
personal sanctions economic sanctions
cutting off
the uh the ability of russian companies
to
raise capital restricting the ability of
russia to sell its treasury bonds and so
on and so forth
but so far none of those have worked
because
they are not designed to be fatal to the
regime
and this is really the key question is
when you're sanctioning a regime
are you into regime change or are you
into
basically sort of punitive actions that
you hope to change behavior
regime change in south korea and
um iran are not great examples of how
sanctions cause regime change the the
mullahs are still in tehran after
after 20 years of sanctions um but the
the the real question is um what can the
west do
what line is to be trod between
something that will punish putin and
something that will actually
destabilize russia now we want putin to
change his behavior and we want
hashenko to change his behavior but we
don't necessarily want
to cause the economic collapse of russia
or belarus for that matter for fear of
something worse
i don't know can you say a bit more
about the relationship between um the
kremlin
and and belarus though to what extent uh
can we see lukachenko's behavior
as being sanctioned by putin is it
conceivable
but they really would have done this if
the kremlin hadn't wanted of course
the kremlin's going through the motions
of saying how appalled they are
but is it really conceivable that they
would have up upset the apple car but
lukashenko would have behaved that way
on his own um
uh i um that's not a question i can
answer uh and i don't think it's a
question that anyone
uh who is not inside the russian or
belarusian governments can actually
credibly answer
but it begs a much a different and more
profound question
and that is who orders this stuff who
actually sort of puts out the death
warrant for
said guest clipper and sends out the gru
guys
with their files of poison you know who
actually sort of
said decided it's a good idea to
download flight
i mean we very often i'm definitely
guilty of this but most journalists who
write about russia and belarus you know
we say putin
as a shorthand for russia lukashenko
shorthand
but actually there is a really strategic
and
an important question is you know
all these actions all these egregious
actions including
uh election hacking in the us are the
actions of
these states security services now uh
obviously putin is a
former member of the security service i
mean he's a child of the kgb
um the kgb the question is does do the
security services
are they ordered are they at the back
and call of putin or kashenko
or are they semi-independent or even
worse do they actually
are they actually calling the shots and
that question is
um again like very hard to answer
because i think it's
it's on a case-by-case basis i mean
already i mean the the the closest we
we've had is there there was that there
was some inquiry into the into the
income murder in 2007 and the crown
prosecution service concluded that there
was strong evidence that putin was
personally involved in approving the
murder of alexander lithuanian in 2007.
there's also
we theresa may said that apparently
putin ordered the skripal poisoning but
again we don't know that
and that's a really that's again a real
real question for
sanctions because we're talking about
sanctions we're talking about actions
that
uh influence policy now is are the
actions of
security services actually a matter of
policy or are the security services
actually doing what the hell they like
and um and i suspect that it's a it's a
sort of muddle
of the two uh i'm sure the the the
security services that which in belarus
is touching is still called the kgb
the the belarusian actual literal kgb
certainly didn't do this without
lukashenko's knowledge and approval i'd
be very surprised if that was the case
but on the other hand you know was it
they that cooked it up did they have any
kind of idea could could
could lukashanka have stopped them
maybe he could have but the point is
that actually it's that
it's that semi-independence between the
notional center of power lukashenko and
putin
and the security services and their
behavior and that disconnect
is actually again one of the reasons why
sanctions
is failing because but right now if but
then
if this is the case then and the rest is
west is out of options
and we've seen what we saw in south
africa to an extent we've seen it
with iran it's pretty difficult to look
at the history of sanctions and points
to
places where they were really successful
they tended to weaken the country
uh to create the make the president the
prime minister feel more embattled
and make it a bit easier for him to say
look at this terrible foreign joint
enemy that we all share isn't isn't the
west terrible
now if it's the case the sanctions are
there because we think something must be
done in sanctions or something
what are other tools i mean short of
military action
is it simply the case that we are
helpless and we pretty much
might as well just admit it we're not
helpless because we we could actually do
much more if we chose to
for example was but but to your point
about tehran i mean
you know the the tehran government
imprisoned um
the entire an entire embassy full of u.s
diplomats they're still
finding that they're still sending bombs
and destabilizing lebanon
and uh and israel and uh and uh and
syria
i mean you know frankly the um but yet
we're still talking to the iranians so
um
you know even if you if you do go to the
very
end of the spectrum which is you decide
that
iran stroke russia or russia is a rogue
state
like russia like iran is a rogue state
you cut off all economic ties
um but you're still left with having to
talk to them to deal with them and
particularly on things like strategic
arms on terrorism and and uh nuclear
uh strategic weapons um uh reduction
treaties and so on
you still you know you you russia is
unfortunately
although it's economically rather weak
it's the 13th biggest economy
in the world it's smaller than south
korea but still it's
uh strategically and militarily
unignorable
so unfortunately you can't
really move further
i mean you could of course if you chose
to make a strategic decision to
completely shut down all economic ties
to the west
but i think the um certainly the biden
administration and people i've
spoken to have been uh advisers also to
obama the previous democratic
administration
uh their strategy is to essentially
play a long game of sort of you know
arms length
engagement rather than burn bridges
right but let's this is a really
important point though because you've
got the biden administration that are
being tested
and you could argue that being tested by
hezbollah right now what's happening in
israel
how far is biden going to back israel
you can argue that what we just saw
in belarus was perhaps the west's under
biden's new leadership
being tested just what will the
americans do
there now so far it seems that biden is
a lot more
let's put it this way predictable than
donald trump and
in opposition when he was there working
under obama biden for example didn't
like the nordstrom 2 gas pipeline
between germany
and russia he said it should be stopped
when he gets into office he hasn't done
really anything to stop it at all the
germans are going
ahead with it so putin now gets to
supply germany
and with lots of gas appeals as far as
he's concerned he's got this great big
financial deal
with germany being done in defiance of
the protest of the european parliament
and without bind doing much to stop it
so
i wonder if biden is about to
demonstrate to putin
and like-minded dictators around the
world that old donald drumsfeld maxim
that weakness is more provocative and
strength that's an excellent question
but i would actually but to that point i
would say that
one of the key tactics for success
of any asymmetric conflict is to provoke
your stronger opponent
into self-defeating acts of overreaction
that's how guerrillas win that's
you know you saw it in northern ireland
you saw it in algeria you saw it
it's if if you and it's and it's all
about provocation and and you know if if
you actually
cause your opponent to actually damage
themselves their credibility
their status uh and so on by provoking
them into hasty actions
then you're winning that game um and i
think that's
the classic case of hezbollah um
russia russia is harder because indeed
as you as you rightly say
germany is a problem germany has
historically had
by far the biggest economic ties and
certainly in terms of foreign investment
actually goes right back to czarist
times
um the the germans are very closely tied
uh to to russia economically gerhard
schweder the former
chancellor was actually an advisor of uh
hired by gasprom on the nordstrom
pipeline the german political elite
still hasn't made that
step but i think things are changing um
in the specific case of nordstrom 2
it's hard to know what biden what more
biden could do because already
america has sanctioned all western
companies from
participating in the construction all of
the final stages of construction is
entirely
gazprom financed in fact so i mean
unless you actually want to
literally sanction germany which has a
you know i mean and
therefore you know derail
uh biden's attempts to rebuild this
broken transatlantic relationship
between the eu
and washington um you're not going to do
that it's not a big enough deal
and i think this is kind of the takeaway
at the end of this i mean it's it's kind
of outrageous it's hooliganism it's
international it's
it's egregiously uh criminal behavior to
try and poison
you know british subjects it's it's it's
it this is an air
the the ryanair incident was an act of
international airline piracy
but it's not as yet
really big enough to warrant a major
strategic reshuffle it's
cheeky it's outrageous we can it does
indeed show our weakness but
i would personally argue that you know a
wise
statesman would actually unfortunately
choose the option of just a rolling eyes
and going with you know
symbolism rather than and
long-term engagement in the hope that
russia is actually going to finally
eventually get back on in within the
fold of fully civilized nations
rather than confrontation because
there's really nothing the west can gain
from confrontation
because if putin were for instance to be
failed
by a crippling economic sanctions that
derailed his regime and destabilized i
promise you were
perhaps a million percent the successor
will not be someone like alexey navalny
he will not be someone from the
liberal opposition it will be someone
fast carrier far more nationalist and
far more dangerous
so um i unfortunately you're right the
west seems impotent but unfortunately
lukashenko and putin are sort of the
devils that we know
and uh she's seriously destabilizing
them risks something far worse and more
dangerous
well i guess all of this certainly makes
international travel that much more
unpredictable
bernie one of our cartoonists has
illustrated
owen's article this week's magazine with
a cartoon with a new
ryanair special offer saying available
now
ryanair mystery tours as seen on tv you
never know where you will land
owen thanks very much indeed now from
belarus
to sweden where the future of the
monarchy is in question over there as it
has been
over here yet again it's a dilemma of
modernization
is the swedish monarchy going woke and
if so can the swedes cope
lisa brookfield answers this question in
the magazine this week and she joins me
now now lisa and fascinating piece you
talk about a cast of characters that we
might not be particularly
in and knowledgeable about versus
princess sophia princess
victoria princess madeleine can you tell
us a little bit about the cast
of characters and this royal drama yes
so just to sum up so chrome princess
victoria is the eldest one she'll
she's the one who will become queen one
day if
the monarchy will survive this royal
awakening as we're going to
talk about uh and then you have princess
sophia
who's married to prince carl philip poor
guy
who was destined to become king but then
we changed the whole thing around
so women can become queens so
so then he had to step back so he's
number two in line to the throne
and then there's princess madeline uh
married to an american
uh living in florida at the moment and
uh they're all quite different
characters
they're all modern princesses in their
own way
and prince victoria you you're saying
that sam no sorry
and you say there's a convention in
sweden that the king
sorry but there's actually an
understanding in sweden that royals
don't do politics there's even
a piece of a swedish constitution
prohibiting the king from talking about
politics but you say that victoria the
crown princess has been
for example speaking in pride marches
and being
active i don't know if you might call it
a civic way but in things that aren't
party politics but she's found
another way to pass her commentary on
social issues
yeah it's very interesting because this
is such a fine line to be threading i
mean is she making
a political statement i mean she's not
making a
a political statement from left to right
but she's certainly making some kind of
statement by
as you say as speaking at pride marches
and
joining a demonstration of the metoo
movement
for example it works
so far because sweden in general is a
very
woke country it's seen as
something very natural to be a committed
to civic society
and to donate money each month to
charities
and such but the question is how far can
they go i mean they are constantly
pushing
these borders princess sophia has been
running a foundation for children in
africa
not controversial at all but now she's
founded a foundation with her husband
prince carl philip
against internet bullying and this is of
course a much more of a hot potato than
helping
poverty-stricken children right and also
we know that prince charles in this
country when he was young
he wrote a book the old man loch negard
it was a children's book which i
remember my parents bought for me
um and prince princess madeline has also
written a children's book but with a
rather different
same plot twist you say yes i think
all of us journalists here when we were
sent out these review copies of stella
the secret we assumed it would be
something about
you know unicorns or dolls or fairies or
standing up
for yourself like generally
you know vague but sort of um
sweet children's book aimed at young
girls but it turned out
it was actually about incest a rather
more
um unexpected topic so so that was the
secret and still
in the secret the secrets that is the
secret it's not like she's got a secret
diary that can fly or something like
that
it's ancestors it's a little bit awkward
uh
but she has been active for many years
just like her mother
queen sylvia in these foundations
uh that work against sexual abuse
against children
and so she does have that um
genuine commitment or have a genuine it
is going to some gala dinner in new york
once a year
you know i have no idea but but she does
have it on paper that that this is not a
uh it's not something you just grab like
i'm going to write a book about incest
there is there is that genuine um
attachment on this issue uh the question
is just should
royals be doing this does she have the
competence
as for example a child psychiatrist
would to bring up these issues
or is it just a way of classic uh virtue
signaling
um no i'm leaning towards the latter
but is this causing any um kind of
kickback in sweden i noticed
an article in svenstag blagett a few
weeks ago
um asking if sweden was ready for its
work monarchy so
are suites noticing a changing pattern
in behavior but the younger oils
are being i don't know socially active
in a way that perhaps they weren't
a generation ago yeah i think so and i
think it's also lots of it
because it's just it's more and more
frequent so if it's once every 10 years
you wouldn't really notice but first it
was like
the me too autumn of 2017 they have this
children's book
you have this um foundation against
internet bullying
and then you had crown princess victoria
and speaking at stockholm fashion week
against damaging ideas and so on and she
has famously been suffering from eating
disorders as well
and just she was and stuck in fashion
week she was she was talking about the
need to for diversity
and ethnic diversity i guess in the
modelling industry here she is taking a
stand
on on equality in an industry that's
perhaps and again it's
it's like it's you know if you want to
look at it from a from a positive
point of view you could say she's got
her own experience from eating disorders
it's great that she's standing up for
for
you know allowing women of all sizes to
exist but then on the other hand it's
like
how ethnically diverse is the swedish
royal family they're all just like
you know white uh upper class people
so so it's a bit if there's always that
fine line like
between doing good work and being
slightly hypocritical
about it and the same goes for the me
too
uh movement and her involvement there of
course since
her father king called gustav has been
accused
of um you know untowardly
behavior or how you would say it um
against women
um he famously just said to journalists
like let let's
not mention this again let's not talk
about it uh swedish journalists were
like okay let's never bring it up again
it's interesting because prince harry
recently did a podcast which he made
great waves he was trashing the american
constitution for example saying he
thought
the free speech protection was bonkers
and a few weeks ago we have the swedish
king
himself giving an interview to a podcast
which must be
a turn up for the book so was he
dropping harry style bombs during that
conversation
unfortunately not but i think just the
fact that he was on
such a trendy podcast which usually just
have celebrities and journalists and
writers
influencers actresses and so on as
guests
and you suddenly have the king this was
absolutely
unexpected and it's certainly one more
step
towards uh a total welcome i'd say
but do the swedish royals need to do
this because they feel that they're not
popular enough
with the young but they're not connected
enough with the country
is there a kind of strategy behind this
are they worried
about their standing i think they're
just really trying to stay relevant
i think they're nervous you know our
king has downsized
the monarchy just as has been the case
in the uk and other countries
just slim lining it focusing on just him
and the air crown princess
victoria and her daughter in official
photographs and such
as you will remember queen elizabeth has
done with um
prince william and his eldest son wasn't
it that kind of
what was the prince charles and william
and the queen yeah so but he's done the
same
um kind of image uh haul over just to
show that
um we don't really cost as much money
because that kind of criticism is all
new in sweden
it's only been in the last few years
that it's uh come up again that is
are they really worth the money and this
is what it what it all
comes down to isn't it are they worth
the
pays money or if they're just gonna go
and be
woke uh like any instagram influences
what's the difference why can't they
just go and do that on their own why do
they need their palaces
uh the diplomatic immunity fancy titles
and all of these advantages that's what
it all comes down to like like um
making a case for your own existence
really
right um but is there a feeling is this
actually upsetting anybody i mean what
is
work to one person might be simple
common sense to another there might be
um of course that the royals will say
the queen's christmas message in this
country
she always talks about the need for
family community maybe if you're talking
about the needs for diversity and
equality
you're simply expressing what is
nowadays a
commonly accepted virtue yes
no you're absolutely right and i think
royals doing good
it's a good thing i mean we've had
royals like um marie antoinette and that
type of royal bearing down on humanity
for centuries so royals that kind of
want to do
too much good should be a good thing
but again it's that fine balance between
being
some sort of superior silent beings
um a remnant from the past that we use
to promote our countries and so on
and just going full-on celebrity um
i mean i mean it's such a fine but i
mean because they shouldn't really be
here should they they shouldn't be here
in 2021.
they're they're saying that they have a
magical special
bloodline that they are in in direct
connection with god
uh it's a complete anomaly in the modern
world and we all know this
um so they have to be like they have to
be modern but they can't be offensively
modern
and uh as we've seen in the case uh with
prince harry of course he's gone full-on
los angeles
woke new age type celebrity and that
hasn't worked
um so we will see if the swedish royal
family can balance it
a bit better and just do kind of slow
modernization but it seems like now
they're getting all eyes on them
and like what it is there's some kind of
silent woke revolution going on here
right but one final question and
princess madeline she sounds a bit like
harry i think she's about the same age
as him
and like him she decided to marry an
american and go off and live on the
other side
of the world so has she been um
giving oprah interviews giving some home
trips about the royal family has she
been behaving because she effectively
has opted out of the swedish royal
circle in the same way that harry wanted
to opt out of ours
i know the interesting thing is that her
opting out it seems so much more genuine
because she's like
yes no reporters i'll just you know i'll
do a bit of work on my foundations
like like a normal um wealthy florida
housewife really taking care of the kids
with the help of
umpteen staff and swimming in her
swimming pool whatever whereas harry is
like please leave us alone and then
he's seeking attention all the time so
his message is totally conflicting
but she's really she has never ever seen
uh been seen as interested in royal work
absolutely so so this is like a logical
development and this is also
um why the king has decided to like cut
down on her official duties and she can
just be
one of the many uh like minor european
royals hanging out somewhere else in the
world jet setting and stuff
and do you think we can expect more of
this do you think the swedish royals are
getting into a trend that they think
that they're renewing their relevance
now and they're going to be
um championship can we expect more
podcast appearances but by the king i
mean recently
he said that sweden's coveted response
had been a mistake
that made worldwide attention by people
who think that he meant that sweden's
lockdowns were a mistake he said he was
talking in general terms
but it seems to me as if we're dipping
the toes into this water a lot more
then they would be a few years ago
absolutely absolutely they are and i
think it's interesting to watch
all of the scandinavians the norwegian
and the swedish and the danish
monarchies
sometimes a danish monarchy is called a
bicycle monarchy i don't know if you've
heard that expression
literally because they ride their
bicycles around copenhagen and
just which is the same kind of monarchy
that we have in sweden and in norway
uh they're very much they're out in the
street uh they're not
show-offs they don't wear hot couture uh
or drive uh
insanely expensive sports cars or
anything like that they're like a down
to earth
type of royal um but yet again one if
you go
to woke it will it will be like okay so
you're really down to earth
you don't like anything at this fancy
life you just want to work for charities
and you just want to save the children
well just drop your royal titles and and
live like a normal
um sven song or anderson why don't you
that i mean that's the end question
always isn't it but they don't really
want to do that
they want to um have the the royal cake
and eat it
and it's the governing principle of our
prime minister boris johnson lisa
bierkeville
thank you very much for taking us
through the magical world of swedish
royalty
now that's it from spectator tv this
week
and if you'd like to avail yourself of
our special offer
you get 20 pounds if you pay 12 pounds
for a three month subscription to the
spectator
in print and online if you do the maths
you'll find out that works out as
negative eight
and how the marketing department passed
that one i just don't know but anyway
you can take it on spectator dot co dot
uk forward slash
tv offer thanks very much for watching
the week in 60 minutes and thanks to our
producers cindy you
and max jeffrey cindy you herself will
be back presenting next week
[Music]
you